depuis des années les tensions
s'accumulent entre la serbie et le
kosovo
après maintes tentatives infructueuses
dans le passé l'union européenne la
france et l'allemagne ont décidé de se
poser en médiateur
une visioconférence est organisée suivie
d'une rencontre à bruxelles entre le
premier ministre kosovar
av du lao ti et le président serbe
aleksandar vucic avec ces pourparlers
l'union européenne dame le pion aux
états unis qui voulaient eux se poser
aussi en médiateur peine perdue ce sont
les européens qui reprennent les choses
en main une position qui n'aurait pas
déplu à donald trump
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle américaine
et pour cause le conflit qui oppose
belgrade à pristina est l'un des litiges
territoriaux et les plus épineux
d'europe
la serbie refuse de reconnaître
l'indépendance du kosovo proclamée en
2008 mais reconnue seulement par une
partie de la communauté internationale
et de l'autre côté le kosovo en cause
des restrictions aux serbes qui peuplent
majoritairement certaines provinces du
nord population qui se disent tant
primes et des problématiques comme la
salle à résoudre pour l'union européenne
qui a tout intérêt à régler ces
différends
car il freine l'europe dans son élan
cette réunion va relancer les
discussions et le travail sur un accord
global et juridiquement contraignant sur
la normalisation des relations entre la
serbie et le kosovo portant sur tous les
dossiers en suspens aleksandar vucic le
président serbe arrive conforté par la
victoire écrasante de son parti du
progrès servent aux législatives de juin
qui le met en position de force et lui
ouvre une voie plus libres pour
s'atteler à la question très sensible du
kosovo de notre côté les consommer
arrive avec un handicap et pas des
moindres leur président hashim thaci
ancien chef de l'ofce qu'à la guérilla
indépendantiste est rattrapé par son
passé
le tribunal spécial a accusé le 24 juin
dernier de crimes de guerre et de crimes
contre l'humanité
le chef d'état kosovar devait justement
se rendre à washington le 27 juin pour
un sommet avec la serbie finalement
annulé hashim thaci a déclaré qu'il
démissionnerait immédiatement si les
accusations du tribunal spécial pour le
kosovo était confirmée par une
inculpation formelle
en rebondissements qui ne plaide pas
vraiment en faveur du kosovo